did you see Jim you would be very
entertained I think did you see Ian
finance he accused somebody of stolen
valor recently this is your cause yes
yes he goes around the city and he
accuses people of stolen not like stolen
dollar do you know you know what I do
sure I because I've used it yes whenever
I want to get on the plane first
I really like those stolen valor videos
of guys at the mall like calling out you
know fake military people so I call out
fake regular it is you tell me what
Stolen Valor Stolen Valor is when I when
a civilian dresses up in like a military
uniform or lies about serving to get the
tension to get like a discount a
discount or be kind of lying or or if
they're homeless to get money sympathy
well I graduated from college and I
still say that you're a college student
so I can get discounts I mean I
graduated a year and a half ago
yeah that's not stolen valleys just a
liar I really thought Mackenzie was
gonna go like oh I do that don't do that
no military guys hate it and they always
catch you because these guys know a lot
about the military they can go to and
three layers deep they've wicked they've
wicked but they know a lot but they
can't go to levels four and five like
why do you have that patch on that side
there's always something that they [ __ ]
up that a real military guy catches and
a military guy would be like Oh where'd
you where'd you go to training and
they're like Fort Bragg they're like who
was your third master sergeant
they're like Jones like bro Williamson
isn't it funny watching the spiral is
they're like oh no I'm losing grip grip
one time a guy called fake - phone call
was like sorry it's my master sergeant
can I remember that right he goes why
would your Master Sergeant call you on a
Saturday it's emergency
he says meaning for lunch I'm you
meeting your master sergeant for lunch
do we not do that and the guys go first
I got now don't do it like the guy was
calling the military guy because he
probably does it all the time yeah cause
people out for that [ __ ] I like it when
people call me boy these guys get killed
overseas and you're [ __ ] dressed up
like him so you can get more attention
in the mall but I also get just as
offended when people do it for everyday
stuff so I like when people get called
out I do tailored not just military but
for really anything yeah yeah now Ian
it's honest I don't know if this is the
video but it's honest oh yeah this is it
yes yes I he found a vintage stolen
valor vintage like he went to a vintage
clothing smell good and it wasn't real
vintage right right and so Ian does not
have issues with public speaking no no
he doesn't have issues making a scene in
public yes I think I have reverse
Asperger Ian is this great ability to
focus on the audience that's going to be
in the phone later yeah and not worry
about the reaction that's happening in
front of him right now
yes because the reaction in front of him
right now is usually very very bad
incredibly bad follow me out of that
interaction and threaten to slap me bad
it confront me on the street and try to
look through my phone does he if I
deleted you on my video bad and do you
delete it no here's a folder you guys
don't check recently deleted yeah why my
interesting story about this the mayor
of one of the guys that the video
followed me do you want to watch the
video for a let's watch the video first
cuz it's incredible I'm on Bedford
Avenue in Brooklyn right now and I see a
case of vintage stolen valor
Stolen Valor this is a real vintage
clothing it's expensive clothing
repurposed to sell to dump trucks for
kids it's not real vintage and you're
not a boat captain just only one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the SiriusXM app
[Music]